Yes. There's it.
Is. Called a chick.
K.o. The icy icy.
I guess i came up here and i was
about. Oh my name's martin.
I've been out of high
school for two years.
I'm writing planning on going
back to university next year.
I came to him when i was about nine so
that means how long is that i'm 19 20 now.
So that's more than 10 years.
I've been up in this area.
I spent probably most of my school years
living in the area if not traveling to
lismore to go to high school i spent the
last three years of primary school here.
And i've sort of seen i've had things to
do with both sides of of nimbin town.
Well there's there's always
been a sort of division or.
A pretty recognizable rift
between between the original
or the the old timers you know the
rednecks the settlers. Their families.
What have you and the alternative
community which came in after 73.
And even though they're sort of pretty
much reconciled now i've noticed that
that division has always been there
and i think it always will be there.
You know and i've seen it not
only in nimbin but but anywhere.
You know where
that where that's how the alternative
sort of our prizing is happened.
It's sort of a it's a big
influential thing on the society
but it's not actually
assimilated into it all that.
Much you know there's a bit of bit
of resentment and stuff behind it.
Right like. Probably a really
vivid memory that i always have.
Was in coming into nimbin
when i was nine years old for the
first time with my aunty and mother
and cousins and people. And it
was a hot summer day really hot
and you know dragonflies
a buzzing around and
and the main thing i could sense was
the smells you know it always has a
distinctive smell which
is really different.
It was a mixture of poor paws and and
grass and sort of you know animals
and sweat and and you know warm
fetid human smells you know
and we just opened up this
big pool pour on this
and this watermelon on
this table and i rt it
and insist the sort of as
my first memory of nimbin.
Was from that time and. Other than that.
I've just got a sort of continuing
memory from when i was younger.
Of summers up in ixtlan which is
sort of just blood and even rocks.
You know the images of summer streams and
the cow shit and the mud and insects
and incense and things like that.
And sort of i think that belongs to
childhood and i don't recap recapture
that anymore. Too much has happened
since to be able to sort of a tree
that type of ideally. Ideally
feeling but it was there.
Well i never consciously realise
that my parents were different
from anyone else's parents.
And it was only i only learnt
externally from other people
and from other people's sort of
disparagement and which meant that
when i go to primary school for example
in you for i was only about nine.
You know i'm wearing the full meat
for will jump. Nothing underneath.
You know big pair of baggy cotton pants
and no underpants no underwear
no shoes long hair feathers
and kids saying you know.
You know really being ostracized
in a school which is really bad
and kids saying oh you know do you ever
wish you had you brush your teeth you know
if you got a disease. You know what
language do you speak type thing
and it was pretty bad for
a while but i don't.
How do i think actually what happened
to our generation my generation is
that after. After going
through that original.
Rejection time by by other peers we actually
became much more conservative than our
parents were which means
that now we're sort of integrating back
into sort of mainstream australian middle
class technological society.
There's a bit of it.
There's a bit of a backlash actually.
You know which is pretty pretty big.
You know i don't go to the commerce school
but my mum taught there for a while like a
lot of friends from there i started off
in the central school which was always a
stronghold of you know dairy farmers sons
and daughters.
Oh. Not once or twice
playground sites. Prejudice.
Just general small minded. You
know typically australian.
Narrow minded thing but the thing about
it was it was never too serious.
You know nothing nothing
too bad ever happened.
It was just always those with the hippies
and those with the good guys you
know the cricket players and stuff.
You're either a cricket player you're
a hippy and hippy didn't play bowls
or cricket or you know something they went
around sort of reading herman hesse or.
Burning incense or you know talking
about shoes christian or something
that you know that's sort of young
kids sort of picking up some.
Those and images themselves i suppose.
Ok. Well we were just always into.
We're into each other which is
something i think a lot of other kids
when we're integers discovering each
other in a sort of pretty personal way.
I just remember. You know
sort of hooking from school
and going down to the river and
swimming and stuff like that.
You know naked and smoking cigarettes and
later on smoking marijuana and girls
and parties
and sort of it was it was a way of life
which we picked up from our parents because
i suppose we you know we imitate our
parents more than anyone else and and
that was just not you know there was only
a group of about six us or something
that did that.
And everyone else was pretty much into
i don't know something barbie dolls
or something. Something else.
Yeah i do i have i have like i actually
when i first came up to an imminent.
I lived in paradise valley for about about
three months before my mum came up from
sydney schuster working
at a school down there.
And i was living with this group of
adults of whom my stepfather was one and.
I really remember their openness
and their sort of generosity
and their sort of feel as ms.
you know that it all sit around
and just i suppose it was a typical middle
class type of adult gathering insofar as
that they were all educated
they'd been to uni.
Psychologists lecturers
teachers doctors and they
but they they had a sense of togetherness
which i really hadn't seen before in the
city you know. I've been brought up going
to various schools in the city you know.
My parents were sort of. Divorced when i
was quite young and a lot type thing.
I was always used to.
Displacement or disembodiment
or something which was which
was alienating or broken apart
and like you know
when i first came to him in the first
thing i saw amongst the adults of this.
Cohesion and.
Just a seriousness of purpose as well you
know an integrity about what they were
doing.
And and they you know they had a lot of fun
too you know i mean it wasn't serious.
There's nothing too serious about there was
no big big you know buddy roster system
or big hippie commune set
i mean they were just.
Intelligent people deciding to have a lot
of fun in their lives you know after
going through the rat race for years and
years and i suppose that me my friends
or picked up on that and we we still are.
Well. We've sort of. We've all moved on
our own individual ways really like.
A lot of my very close friends from paving
from the early days have gone on to uni
like one of them has just graduated with
honors in europe biology at a new he's
often england at the moment looking at unis
over there which is pretty impressive.
You know my sister is down sydney
finishing off an economics degree
and other things
and others of us are still up here like
myself like luke who plays music i play
music we we do things i write as well
and that's all right we
sort of i think really
that nimbin didn't have
such an impact on us
that we were going to fall into one of its
types of categories whether it was get
too far into drugs that we became junkies
or become full on hippies or whatever.
We're going to do we followed our own
paths. You know which were all different.
Some of us haven't been back if.
Years.
I'm definitely. Absolutely. Well.
The people who who i knew as
a kid who i now know to be
you know full on addicts.
Quite seriously ruined by drugs by
hard drugs were always a bit a bit
self-destructive anyway and whether
they're in yemen or wherever they were
or where they were in the streets of
chippendale surry hills or brunswick street
or wherever they were. Those are the types
of people who are going to get into
that. Anyway so i don't think
there's always an argument
that nimbin produces the circumstances
for people to become junkies but i think
that that that that's i
don't person's choice.
So i mean i i remember a girl
who who was really amazing.
And she she taught me how to ride a horse.
I knew for years like for seven years
or something and last year i learned
that she died of an idea in brisbane
and that that really threw me a lot
and she didn't have any friends.
She just couldn't handle it so she died
and you know there's quite a
few stories like that around.
But then again they're
people who have sort of.
Not seen or heard of quite a few years now
and they disappeared into the woodwork
and there's no there's no thing about
nimbin there's no real support system for
people who have got into
that type of thing.
I don't know whether that that
should be a social concern
or a hospital concern i was sort of.
Parents concerned but for all the kids who
are out there on their own and homeless.
There's no real support system for them.
And that's pretty sad and
you know it's pretty bad.
Some.
Marijuana fitted into into the
usual young semi rebellious semi
celebration resort of thing about
you know just being out there
and getting away from your parents without
hippies or bureaucrats or businessman
or whatever they were getting away
from them getting away from school.
Getting away from your own
ambitions whatever it is
and having a good time with your friends
and it was never a serious thing for me.
I mean i haven't smoked for a long time
and lot of my friends haven't either.
They've so left that you go left alone
when they finish high school and.
It does change it does sort of.
Affect affect your development in certain
ways it opens you up to different
different thoughts and different
ways of looking at things
but then again it's like any drug it's
recreational as. If you have too much of it.
It's not good for you. You know so
marijuana is the thing about my one of
that was it. Lots of people going
to dealing which is pretty.
I don't know i was i was sort
of was critical of that.
Because i thought there was a better.
You know better things to do
than get into dealing marijuana
and they're still doing it and i
think that's a destructive force
and my own peers and i my
own sort of generation.
But you know again that's their choice.
And i sort of i can't i find it hard to
be able to justify a lot of people's
reasons for doing things and i can only
put it down to being their choice.
So marijuana is something that.
That all of us experience that
people do experience everywhere.
Wherever they are and it's great
it's a great thing. It's like.
It's like anything it's like
joys of life you know. And.
It's just it's just a matter of
abuse and acceptance. I suppose.
Yes absolutely absolutely.
When i remember that when i was 10 i was
fully into drama and i don't know why
but drama was it and i remember just reading
shakespeare and reading a lot because.
And what we decided there was the start of
a new nimbin drama troupe you know just
of young kids primary
school age kids. And.
I remember we put on about two productions
of various things like arthur miller
and. People like that.
And i remember writing two plays really
funny little sort of plays about i don't
know just about us. I suppose. And
we actually put the mining town.
You know audiences came and it was
drinks and wine and cheese and music
and it was really good and that happened.
You know probably when i was 11
and 12 which is a young time
that happened there was also classical music
society which i played out every week
which was really good for
furthering you know mine
and everyone else's musical
sort of skill or practice
or whatever you know we used
to sort of have weekly.
Gatherings at the town hall and about
eight o'clock on sunday nights.
And just play music for hours.
People see running cushions and i'd
get up and play some clarinet sonata
and my sister play the cello and mother
play the piano and it was really good.
It was always very informal i mean
i'm sure squeaking the whole time.
You know that was acceptable.
Yeah so definitely there was a
lot of a lot of help in us as
far as getting us into our own thing was
concerned you know whether it was musical
skateboarding or whatever the
hell it was you know it was
or always alright to be doing those things
you know you didn't have to be going off
and achieving what school you
didn't have to be. You know.
Fulfilling the expectations of your
grandparents or or your parents
or your teachers or whatever it was.
It was always very much an individual
orientated thing i don't know whether it was
more so than your else but.
But it seemed
that way.
That's really true not
only is it a challenge.
It's a yeah it's a.
Being in nimbin and feeling the
need to break out of nimbin.
And go to the city and achieve something
else is not only a challenge.
It's also a very difficult thing to do
emotionally because once you've been up here.
If you've been up here for as long as
i have which is more than 10 years.
You become really attached to
what is basically a paradise
and you begin to wonder well is there really
need to go to the city is there really
need to get a degree is there
a need to achieve something
and become a sort of working functioning
member of a sort of open society
and you really think no there
isn't a need for that.
But yes it's a challenge and
it's a it's a nice challenge
but i think nimbin is a place we will all
come back to you know all the time we
will be coming back i've
always come back here.
Ferals. I think i don't remember.
There always being cells actually i think
feral seems to be one of the latest
phases of existential billion
whether whether it's.
Comes from from punk from
skinheads and from whatever.
I don't really.
I just think that ferals it's important
for whoever decides to become that. Out.
Lee contemptuous of everything learns
how to integrate at some point
and the fact is
that all of the fellows do live off the
government which isn't isn't a bad thing
or anything but you know that's
how we work our society but.
It would be nice if one day they they
learnt how to make furniture or something
and they set up workshops and they
sold so naturally they sold handcrafts
or goods or clothes or something like
that because at the moment they're
really quite a bit abusive
and they're a bit exploitative
of their environment.
Not i don't know. I've
never really had any.
Any interaction with fell apart
from meeting them in it in a creek
or getting stoned with them or something.
I think they're just fun loving people
who just want to have a good time
but it's a juvenile type of thing.
It's an important thing but it's
juvenile and i think it's something
that had to go out of eventually.
Well.
They've always seemed to sort of revolve
around around what's happening drug wise.
I think that's sounds
like a general statement
but that's first it was always just a peace
loving hippie you know stereotypical
60s american images of the hippie who who
really just wanted to live peacefully on
a communist might be or join. Smack
came in cocaine in all this stuff.
You know designer drugs are in
there now and people are changing.
You know you get sort of yuppie middle
class suburbanites from brisbane
or sydney coming up
and down to to buy their drugs they're
setting up little businesses and
and what have you so newman's lost its
original idealistic sort of cohesion
and it's become a bit disparate and
a bit sort of a bit scattered in
that way you know. The drug
culture has has given it.
Such a commercial centre as far.
As business is concerned that there's
no real social conscience anymore
and that's sad because you can see it in
the street you can see it in the people
but at the same time it's
becoming much more ordinary.
And it's it's turning into a pretty peaceful
middle class hamlet at the same time
where whereby you've got.
Families who aren't into drugs at all
or aren't into anything
to alternative coming up.
Having kids living and actually
living really peaceful
and you know ecologically sound
and happy lives out in the hills.
You know what i suppose they
are environmentally conscious
but it's not it's not a self-conscious
thing like it was in the early days
and that's really good and
i think the more of that
that happens everywhere around australia
the better because it needn't be.
It needn't be sudden or revolutionary or
or aggressive towards the old
settlers there like it wasn't 73.
But it can be integrated
into the mainstream society.
You know which simply just means
learning how to live with.
With an awareness about what
you're doing with your rubbish.
You know where you're putting a plastic
where you're putting your bottles where
you're putting your shit.
You know working out how you can use you
use your own land for the most most
convenient purposes
and efficient purposes without
destroying what you've got which is what
permaculture is all about
and that started off here
and learning about the social
the social sort of relevance of
that as far as your kids are concerned
and what school to send them to
or things like that. You know.
And that's that's where nimbin has its
strengths now it doesn't have it in the old.
Nostalgic your earnings
of doped up people.
It's got it in the hard working
conscious and yet mainstream.
Middle class trend that's been happening
in the last five years and other than
that other than the sort of other
than the yuppie drug scene and
and the middle class family
saying shall i put it.
I can't really think of there
being any other major strand.
There's always the
rebellious clique from syd.
Here from newtown from glee who decide
to come up and check on him by now.
But it's usually a bit too slow and they
end up going back back home to sydney
or there's.
Others there's a bit of an aboriginal
community developing as well which is good
because i always i always
noticed conspicuously
that there weren't many aboriginals
in the ambon and now there are more
and they're actually getting land for
example there's a there's quite a large
community at the base of nimbin rocks.
Who have reclaimed their land and it's
their land and they all live there
and it's really good and
that they're quite happy in.
And everyone interacts with them and they
inject with us and it's really good.
So it's you know it's pretty much all big
one family as far as they're concerned
now which is good.
Apart from
that i can't think of any other subcultural
trend that's taking place in the.
Well it's. There are a few there are
a few of us who decided to do that
but it's much less self-consciously alternative
than what our parents were what the
basically people who who want to settle
down. Have families if they can live.
You know live in their own
house. If they can afford that.
But they're also basically people who are
still training for some some sort of
occupation you haven't got
any any real livelihood yet.
And so they're not really
getting into permaculture
and they're not really getting into into
hippiedom as such what they're getting
into is just staying up here
rather than going to the city.
So i don't know whether
that's a regressive step
or what it is i don't think it's it
really matters to make a judgment on
that level but. But they're they're much
more ordinary about things you know.
And most of them on the dole.
You know i'll be getting the dollar
a couple of months or something.
After i've waited for 13 weeks but.
Yeah it's sort of there's a lot of.
There's a lot of pull towards
just stay instead of going.
And i think it'll change i think over the
next few decades then will become so much
more of an ordinary
place. You know i can't.
It will become pretty much a country
town with. With different tendencies.
You know
and that's about it.
Well i think it's a very
simple thing which is that
when you've been exposed to such
a wide variety of different life
lifestyle options.
You know it comes as no surprise that
what you would naturally get is is a wide
and open and accepting
and tolerating view of the society as a
whole which i suppose on a personal level
means that that haven't been brought
up in sydney as a young kid
and sort of gone to private schools
until i was seven or six or whatever.
You know it's a close type of life the
close lifestyle it's very much a middle
class protected financially secure.
Conservative type of way of of living.
Coming up here just opened me
up to a completely different.
Freedom which which unfortunately a lot
of people in this country haven't got the
opportunity to experience you know.
And so it's living growing up up here has
opened me to a whole different range of
spiritual practices. And i mean you know.
The simple fact that there's
there's a christian.
Christian a sort of settlement in the
will and bar that there's so much.
There's so much eastern
discipline which is.
Seriously followed up
here is is impressive.
You know to a young person to young
person's impressionable mind.
And that's something which i just know
wouldn't have been an issue in sydney
and i can see it now because
i had friends in sydney.
When i was a kid and and i still know them
and we've grown up parallel although
they've grown up down there
and i've grown up up here and they and
they're sort of into what they're doing
but they're very commercially orientated
they're very consumer orientated they're
much more into finding out what money
they can get hold of whatever they can.
They're into urban types of.
Types of hobbies you know
they while i was doing drama
or something up here they were doing
skateboarding in the streets of manly
or whatever you know while i was smoking
marijuana they were probably taking
ecstasy or designer drugs you know stuff.
It's just a different
type of slant on things.
One is a bit more competitive
in rat race than the other.
And each have their sort of negative
tendencies in their positive tendencies.
But i think that the mere fact
that being up here for so long
and experiencing the different
types of people i have up here.
You know for as many years
i have means that. That.
Me and young people like
myself have got quite a wide
and accepting view. More educated
view more informed about.
About australian society and
and it's sort of subcultures
as a whole you know.
It's a it's a general sort of
statement but i think i think.
The wider view you have the more the more
informed you are about your society.
Well. Well it is totally confusing the
thing about the spiritual sort of.
Aether that is playing
around in these hills is
that people become very
self-indulgent and they.
They become quite self preoccupied which
is you know which i suppose is alright for
an individual in some part of his life
but in the end you've got to get down
to the real the real hard work you know
digging the ship and
and so you know what you probably see up
here is a lot of of quite precious people
going around spouting forth
a little philosophies.
But see that's you know
that's what it's all about.
You've got to have somewhere
in the country that does
that you know not everyone can be out
being business executives or something.
You know noting their fast buck you know
someone's got to be delivering their
philosophy. However half baked they may
be so that's what it's like up here
and you know and it's good because.
In the end it is confusing.
You're right you know it is confusing.
There's a lot of stuff that's
going around and for it.
You know especially before
you've developed your own.
Your own firm beliefs about the world.
It's hard to know which
are really where it's at
or not you know a lot of them
are just real crap you know
and a lot of them are
quite quite inspiring.
So i mean there's a lot of
you've got you've got a cultists
transcendentalists yogis set on you.
Sadhus all those people out there doing
what they do and i suppose you witness it.
And you observe a new appreciation
and you take your choice.
Ah well yeah. Do i have one.
Oh look i you know there's
so many stupid here.
I think is i really can't can't choose i
now. Know i really can't think of one.
I can't think of one.
Funny nimbin story.
I can't. It's hard to think
single one of my head.
Well.
For me for me the real the real beauty in
the real importance about living up here
is been the natural the natural
abundance of the place which has meant
that over the years i've i've really
learned how to add to live out there
and you know which which included.
Trips walking days across the nightcap
range ridge from from then been here
to the base of the mound in the
hills. You know which meant.
Sort of getting on my
horse with some friends
and for three days camping in writing from
here through the forest up to the base
of the pinnacle over there which
you can see you know which.
Which meant just being so inspired
by the landscape that i'd go out
and buy a canvas and paints to try
and paint what i could see
pretty poorly probably.
But you know it's just such an
inspiring thing to be in you know.
Having having the opportunity to go
down to hang on falls every week
and swim down there in this amazing
natural water full well and all of
that it's just it's amazing thing to be
able to do as a kid when you're going up
and i really. I do pity a
lot of a lot of people who.
Who just haven't known that part
that part about australia or
that part about being out in the country.
And sort of hippiedom and drug
culture and all of that is around.
But for me it always lies.